primero encuentro en el parlamento
richizona que respondió a la ronda de
preguntas de la oposición donde fue
criticado por volver a nombrar a la
ministra del interior suela bravoman
considerada el ala derecha de los
Stories y quien tiene una fuerte línea
sobre la inmigración la ministra
renunció hace una semana Entonces por
incumplir las normas del gobierno
todos podemos ver lo que ha pasado aquí
el Primer Ministro es tan débil que ha
hecho un trato sucio comerciando con la
seguridad nacional porque tenía miedo de
perder otra elección de Liderazgo hay
nuevotoría en la cima pero como siempre
con ellos el partido primero el país
después
le salió al paso a sus detractores
ha preguntado por la ministra del
interior la ministra del interior
cometió un error de apreciación pero lo
reconoció planteó el asunto y aceptó su
error y por eso estoy encantado de darle
la bienvenida de nuevo a un gabinete
Unido que aporta experiencia y
estabilidad al corazón del gobierno
el Primer Ministro también respondió por
los planes para superar la crisis
económica en la que está asumido Reino
Unido
señor presidente he sido sincero
Tendremos que tomar decisiones difíciles
para restaurar la estabilidad económica
y la confianza y mi honorable amigo el
ministro lo expondrá en una declaración
de otoño dentro de unas semanas
el esperado anunció que pretende
recuperar las finanzas públicas fue
pospuesto del 31 de octubre al 17 de
noviembre este aplazamiento la primera
decisión política de sunak desde que
tomó el relevo detrás pondrá más presión
sobre el Banco Central de Inglaterra que
en su reunión del 3 de noviembre deberá
decidir si sube o no las tasas de
interés para controlar una inflación
desenfrenada sin conocer aún los planes
del gobierno